die weltwoche auf der anklagebank bei
dem zürcher prozessen herzlich
willkommen bei kulturplatz extra hier im
zürcher theater neumarkt wurde dieses
wochenende eine reale wochenzeitung in
einem fiktiven prozess auf der
theaterbühne verteidigt es ging um
pressefreiheit und um die verletzung
gesellschaftlicher verantwortung ein
einmaliges experiment vor einem
inszenierten gericht aber mit echten
akteuren
wir haben alle drei prozesstage
beobachtet und blicken nun zurück es
geht wieder um zensur
noch geht es darum journalisten oder
zeitungen ein maulkorb zu gehen wenn wir
damit anfangen sind so zu betreiben in
irgendeiner form auch selbstzensur
das ist der beginn vom ende der offenen
gesellschaft es geht um die frage dass
auch journalist nicht im rechtsfreien
raum leben inmitten unserer
tschechischen republik wie ein organ das
er bauer sieht diffamiert minderheiten
diskriminiert und unsere nationalen wie
internationalen institutionen der
freiheit diskreditieren die weltwoche
steht vor gericht
wenn auch nur im theater angeklagt gegen
drei artikeln des schweizerischen
strafgesetzbuches verstoßen zu haben
gegen das verbot die bevölkerung zu
schrecken
gegen das verbot der
rassendiskriminierung gegen das verbot
die verfassungsmäßige ordnung zu stören
den ihren artikeln soll die weltwoche
gegen minderheiten gehetzt panik
verbreitet und verfassungsorgane
diskriminiert haben ein schwerwiegender
vorwurf meinungsbildung in einer
demokratie steht hier auf dem prüfstand
die idee zu den zürcher prozessen stammt
vom regisseur milo rau
für ihn geht es nicht allein um die
weltwoche er will im theater ein forum
bieten das den dialog fernab politische
grabenkämpfe ermöglicht welche rolle
spielt wahrheit welche rolle spielt
meinungsfreiheit in einer demokratie
kurz vor beginn der zürcher prozesse
frage ich mir nach seiner ganz
persönlichen motivation
ich will zeigen die weges ziel also dass
weiterhin durch direkte wattierte ist
wichtiger als das urteil einfluss in 14
stunden trip bühne sich in aussage
machen sie wirkt tiefgründig befragt und
lebe zum schluss ich sagte pendelt er
schuldig oder unschuldig ausfallen das
ist gesellschaft die verantwortung
wichtiger ist hart recherche
journalismus wichtiger wie es dann am
schluss fa ich denke abhängig von den
geschworenen ist schnell rückte wichtig
punkt sondern das was vorher passieren
letzte vorbereitungen lampenfieber vor
der ersten sitzung als moderatorin
fungiert die verlegerin anrufer
unterstützt von alt bundesrichter jed
neu als rechtsexperten die anklage
vertritt der jurist mark special auf
seiner seite der österreichische
journalist probierte music verteidigt
wird die weltwoche vom promi anwalt
valentin landmann und svp kantonsrat
claudio zanetti beginnt der zürcher
prozesse die geschworenen werden
vorgestellt
ein hoffentlich repräsentativer
querschnitt den es zu überzeugen
geschworene nummer drei bitte nennen sie
ihren namen
ich heiße vertreter für welchen beruf
üben sie zurzeit aus ich bin rentnerin
ich arbeite als sitznachbar im spital
und als freier mitarbeiter für den
regionalteil einer zeitung geschoren
nummer sechs welchen beruf üben sie
zurzeit aus ich bin zurzeit maturandin
an der kreis stadelhofen haben sie in
ihrer beziehung zu einer der parteien
nein sind sie bereit nach bestem wissen
und gewissen über die hier vorgelegten
fragen ohne ansehen von person herkunft
und politische ausrichtung zu
entscheiden ja möchten sie noch etwas
anfügen nein die anklage beginnt mit
ihrem plädoyer
sehr geehrte frau vorsitzende
geschätztes präsidium wehrte geschworene
die situation ist paradox
mein kollege musik und ich vertreten
hier im namen der aufgedrehten
öffentlichkeit
die anklage gegen eine bestimmte
spielart der medienfreiheit obwohl wir
mit schreib- und rhede verboten nichts
am hut haben lügen bleiben auch dann
lügen wenn sie unter dem deckmantel der
meinungsfreiheit daherkommen
eine erste antwort von seiten der
verteidigung
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
es geht um ganz fundamentaler rechte
bei freiheitsrechten wie der
pressefreiheit müssen wir sehr sorge
tragen dass sorge tragen ist auch eine
gesellschaftliche verantwortung von uns
alle
damit möchte ich meinem co verteidiger
herrn zanetti übergeben
präsidentin hoch höchstgericht das kleid
wurde sie genannt die liberale
propaganda und was heißt schon liberalen
liberalen seite von ihren libero
freiheitlich muss man sie und freiheit
gottes und ich bin überzeugt dass sie
wüssten dass man zum freiheit gottes
ganz pflanzlich und möglichst wenig sinn
der nummer hatte und bei der freiheit
geht immer um freiheit vom donnerstag
hiermit ist die heutige verhandlung
geschlossen
denn hier im saal des theater neumarkt
wo gleich die zweite sitzung der zürcher
prozesse beginnt bei der eröffnung
wurden die klingen vor allem rhetorisch
gekreuzt jetzt geht es weiter mit den
richtigen verhandlungen und der anhörung
der experten darunter bekannte
journalisten politiker und juristen
nichts ist vorhersehbar ein experiment
im geschützten rahmen dieser spielanlage
hier
und doch geht das was hier verhandelt
wird uns alle etwas an und zwar
persönlich schließlich geht es um die
meinungsfreiheit in unserer demokratie
das erklärte ziel von spielleiter also
regisseur milo rau ist der
gesellschaftliche diskurs
jetzt geht es also los mit dem ersten
von drei anklagepunkten artikel 258 des
strafgesetzbuches streckung der
bevölkerung gemäß artikel 258 des
strafgesetzbuches macht sich schuldig
wer die bevölkerung durch androhen und
vorspiegeln einer gefahr für leib und
leben in schrecken versetzt
die anklage wirft der weltwoche vor
nachhaltig die bevölkerung durch
feindbilder besonders durch das bild
eines angeblich aggressiven islam zu
verunsichern
der punkt ist dass systematisch endet
werden in der bevölkerung dass sie ihre
unbesorgt haid verliert ihr die
geborgenheit im recht wie man also seite
sie nur behauptet dass das system
funktioniert will sie bedroht sich fühlt
umso dunkler mächte unterschwellig
überdies können und herrschaft
übernehmen
die weltwoche schreibt wer den islam
ernst nimmt sieht ihn als polit
religiöser eroberungs ideologie muslime
seien ohnehin schwer integrierbar und
hätten die absicht auf schweizer boden
ihrer kultur exklusiver und sichtbarer
auszuleben
knallhart recherchiert oder pure
angstmacherei punkt
die zürcher prozesse
erste anklagepunkt rängen der
bevölkerung action die anleger erhält
das wort sie haben zehn minuten
das minarett wurde bekanntlich verboten
die weltwoche verbietet nicht nur das
sondern sie begründet dies damit dass
sich unter den minaretten eine
brutstätte des terrors ausbreiten könnte
und damit sind wir beim thema der
schreck und der bevölkerung die geistige
brandstiftung
das ist das thema und nicht
grundsätzlich die medienfreiheit
tatbestand der track ist der 50 das wort
hält die verteidigung und spaß beiseite
der islam ist nicht kastriert wenn man
ihm die mitarbeiter abschneidet die un-
besorgtheit der schweizer ist ohnehin
tangiert durch die ganze thematik
brandstiftung ist es wenn wir einen
solchen ansatz hineinbringen in unsere
diskussion
wir sollen nicht zeitschriften
verbrennen
wir wollen die diskussion zu lassen wir
beginnen mit den kreuzverhören als
erster experte der ehemalige weltwoche
journalist albert kuhn
er verließ die weltwoche aufgrund ihrer
wie er sagt sehr vogelhaltung ich
schaffe so kommentare gehabt ja jetzt
denn arbeitest du im cockpit des bösen
und hab ich anfangs sehr herzlich
gelacht so also wie ich das dann zum
briefkasten herausnahmen dadurch
wirklich entsetzt sagte er
wisst ihr krieg also es war einfach es
war das minarett plakat dass das jetzt
wenn wenn du jetzt nicht gehst gehst du
nie mehr nächster zeuge ist daniel
clowes auch er verließ die weltwoche
wurde ihnen von der redaktion
vorgeschrieben was bei ihren recherchen
heraus kommen muss hatten sie den
eindruck dass man sie beauftragt angst
zu verbreiten nein
haben sie bewusst mit falschen tatsachen
angst verbreitet nein eine studie aus
deutschland das 50 radikalen muslime
konvertiten sind können sie das in ihrer
arbeit bestätigt ich kann es nicht so
beurteilen glas nehmen platz nicolas
blancho präsident des islamischen
zentralrats der schweiz von der
weltwoche als wien lagen in wien
bezeichnet in welchem verhältnis stehen
sie zur angeklagten in können sehr guten
verhältnis wie man das natürlich
verstehen kann
navigation für sie insbesondere auch in
bezug auf die muslimische minderheit ist
jetzt meine das trübt natürlich auch zu
dieser ganzen sache bei und der liebe
philipp gut der diesen artikel auch
mitgeschrieben hat ist er leider heute
nicht da und auch der liebe goebbels an
1 köppl heißt ja ja da ist ja auch nicht
da ich aus mit dem flugzeug die woche
zehn flügen auch von verteidigung
verteidiger ich frage mich
lassen sie den zeugen antworten und
spreche nicht nur sie lassen sich sie
eine frage
bald haben den zeugen zuletzt antworten
danke die nächste frage stellen würden
sie sich als islamist bezeichnen was
islam ist
ich bin ein muslim aus dem mainstream
sowie viele muslime im mainstream sich
befinden und ich würde nicht us
mainstream mussten bezeichnen
als nächste im kreuzverhör
islamwissenschaftlerin amira hafner als
apache die weltwoche tut etwas in einem
höheren maß was andere medien auch tun
sie nimmt einen aus meiner sicht sehr
problematischen anteil des islams eines
gelebten islams einer islamischen
ideologie und stilisiert sie zur norm
ich hab's und nützte gaga wenn die
problematische zeit bat ich finde das
ist sogar pflicht machen
andere medien zum teil machen muss das
kann ich nicht beurteilen da müsste ich
mir systematisch ich mache nicht mehr
die wissenschafter ausschließlich
aufgrund von der thematik wird aber
langsam knapp zum kochen
ich griff waldwochen nicht ich bin rein
durch weltwoche angriffe
drei stunden verhandlung sieben experten
ein marathon unterschiedlichste
argumente panikmache streckung der
bevölkerung oder fundierter journalismus
das bleibt noch immer die frage kaum ein
presse sieht in der schweiz wird der
arzt mit einer einzelnen person in
verbindung gebracht wie die weltwoche
mit roger köppel wie wir gehört haben
dreht der platz macher nicht in den
zeugenstand er kommt aber dennoch nicht
drum herum um dieses theater er ist der
grosse abwesende bei den zürcher
prozessen roger köppel ideologe
chefredaktor verleger und eigentümer der
weltwoche
warum lässt er die zürcher prozesse
links liegen wollen wir wissen
bei acht die rutsche körper kommt vors
volksgericht steht das gut einfach nett
das ist fundamental asymmetrie
ich stehe natürlich foren wichtig wenn
sie noch klappt daran mich muss vor
gericht sieht auch komisch aber nicht im
sinn von theatralische spielerischen
inszeniert als achtjährige könnten
conny pohlers falsches gericht steht
dabei liebt er das rampenlicht tritt mit
roger schawinski durch die schweiz ist
gern gesehener gast in deutschen
talkshows wo er als muster schweizer mit
schrägen ansichten auffällt nur den
zürcher prozessen verweigert er sich
kein interesse es ist interessant
ein interessanter vorgang für mich und
ich lege die zürcher prozess so als
symptom für mich aber noch heiß für was
eigentlich also auf 3 ist natürlich eine
offenkundige ist in hand vor der
intoleranz da also dass man rechtzeitig
wo sich viele einig vielfalt ist jetzt
wahr missstand im staat aufdeckt deshalb
ruft die dich und das schwimmen ein
autokratisches statistik vor gericht
stellen das ist ja eigentlich alles
zeichen gipfel vor intoleranz eigentlich
auf transit muss man aber heraus zu gute
halten dass er mir im interview und
spreche immer wieder gesagt hat ihm geht
es darum die tabuisierung wochen erfährt
die bestimmte kreise für dich vorher
sich bewegt kulturkreise dass ich möchte
durchbrach also es ist ein ambivalentes
auch rhetoriker komplett bestimmt
zusätzliche würze in die zürcher
prozesse gebracht als nächstes geht es
hier weiter mit der verhandlung des
zweiten anklagepunkt artikel 261 des
strafgesetzbuches über
rassendiskriminierung gemäß artikel 2
161 des strafgesetzbuches macht sich
schuldig wer öffentlich ideologien
verbreitet die auf die systematische
herabsetzung der angehörigen einer rasse
ethnie oder religion gerichtet sind
die anklage wirft der weltwoche vor sie
würde wiederholt ein negatives bild von
bestimmten bevölkerungsgruppen zeichnen
zb gewaltbereite muslime oder auch
kriminelle roma minderheit verächtlich
gemacht werden dass sie diskriminiert
werden dass sie ausgegrenzt werden dass
sie stempelt wirken stigmatisiert werden
und das einzelfälle pauschalisiert
werden auf ganze gruppe da man kann die
nicht verallgemeinern und eine ganze
gruppe negative stereotype zu
erschließen so behauptet die weltwoche
pauschal immigranten hätten keine
hemmungen das üppige angebot des
sozialstaates voll auszuschöpfen
an anderer stelle fragt sie ob es
genetisch bedingt sei dass muslime
erfolgloser sind als andere einwanderer
die klare position der weltwoche lautet
ungebremste zuwanderung verschärft
konflikte mit dem straftatbestand sind
wirklich und wie zwischen glaubt sondern
du mich drauf norm will viel so dass
rassismus zu häufig aber persönliche
gesellschaftliche aufgabe wobei das ist
aber wohl dass die grenzen nicht ohne
schläge und da muss ich also nirgends
bundesbürger frage wo damit winkt das
publikum wartet gespannt denn in dieser
sitzung wird der journalist alex baur
auftreten er ist der einzige autor der
weltwoche der sich diesen theater
prozess stellt
die türe prozesse anklagepunkt zwei
rassendiskriminierung action
bitte nehmen sie platz die sitzung ist
eröffnet als experte rufe ich alex baur
den zeugenstand
sind sie bereit in diesen prozess nach
besten wissen und gewissen auszusagen
das bin ich ich hätte aber einen kleinen
ordnungsantrag und zwar dass ich nicht
als zeuge sondern als auskunftsperson
genannt und stellen im zweiten stunde
ich möchte sie einfach darauf aufmerksam
machen dass sie mich vielleicht mit
verurteilen müssen weil ich für jedes
wort das er geschrieben habe darf ist
das darf ich bitte ausführen herrn mai
wird das verstehen
ich möchte sie einfach darauf aufmerksam
machen dass ich für jedes wort das ich
geschrieben haben
auch für jeden titel die volle
verantwortung tragen und übernehmen wenn
es zur kenntnis
exemplarisch für den diskriminierenden
journalismus der weltwoche gegenüber den
muslimen ist eine artikel serie von alex
baur über das zürcher sozialamt alle
protagonisten dieser artikel stammen aus
muslimischen ländern wie tunesien dem
kosovo der türkei libyen pakistan und so
weiter als gäbe es unter schweizern
keine sozialhilfe bezieher geschweige
denn betrüger als lese bekomme ich den
eindruck also das ist eine spezialität
dieser herkunftsgruppe oder warum
erwähnen sie keine fälle von schweizern
weil ich keine orte aber dann müssten
sie doch sich fragen ob das eine seriöse
untersuchung ist ist da nicht jemand auf
dem auge vielleicht auf dem rechten oder
linken auge blind
also ich muss insofern korrigieren es
gibt sicher auch unter den schweizern
auch für den schweizer ist es ziemlich
in schwieriger sozialhilfe zu betrügen
weil sie technische fragen kommen sie
darauf wie ich darauf komme
sie haben das beispiel zum beispiel mit
der kommunikation mit einem ausländer
der kein wort deutsch spricht dagegen
die sozialarbeiter das ist natürlich die
geben einfach schnell
schneller auf und fragen nicht weiter
weil es einfach sehr kompliziert ist
wenn sie ein haus im kosovo sie
unterstellen jetzt denn ja den
sozialarbeitern kapitulation genau
vorgeschrieben und das sind sie
das ist so das hat man aus diesen akten
zum teil sehr schön gesehen ich habe ja
nicht nur fälle beschrieben sondern ich
habe diese akten und ich habe diese
diese fall es war eigentlich fallstudien
unter hat man sehr schön gesehen ja sie
haben selbst erwähnt statistiken wie
viel prozent von welchen
einwanderungsgruppen bei der sozialhilfe
landen darf man so etwas erheben
ja ich habe man muss dass man darf nicht
nur man muss das machen das wurde lange
nicht gemacht eben aus einer falsch
verstandenen zurückhaltung weil das sind
auch wichtige randbedingungen und in der
bevölkerung merkt man das auch und da
muss man auch darüber diskutieren ich
finde gefährlich wird es erst wenn man
diese dinge unterdrückt wenn man nicht
darüber spricht dann wird es gefährlich
ich habe gelesen diese akten wurden
ihnen anonymisiert übergeben das heißt
man hat deutlich gesehen werde es ist
also ich verstehe sich aber niemand
gestellt
aber ich verstehe es jetzt nicht haben
sie überhaupt gewusst welchen namen und
herkunft diese leute haben wenn sie
anonymisiert übergeben sind
oder haben sich das einfach erfunden
dass die aldi hat nein ich habe nichts
erfunden das hat man gesehen aus den
akten herkunft alter viele persönliche
daten die ich natürlich auch nicht
veröffentlicht habe aber das konnte man
erkennen wo die diese leute her und das
ist ausgewiesen
gut aber erstmal bin ich ganz ihrer
meinung muss ich diese dinge anschauen
ist sieht man dann auch die frage mit
welchen zungenschlag man quasi die
generalisierungen macht aber zwischen 30
40 20 prozent und 100 prozent in ihren
artikeln ist ja dann doch noch ein
unterschied der sich als recht positiv
diese 100 prozent gelesen ich habe das
nie
naja 12 von 12 so gut kann man rechnen
sind 100 prozent die statistische frage
der und alex baur war natürlich nicht
der einzige zeuge zu diesem anklagepunkt
es kam zu außergewöhnlichen begegnungen
sozialen für experte schmidt lieferte
sich ein duell mit der verteidigung der
ob-wahl buch wichtige frage diskutiert
noch ausdiskutiert wichtig macht ob in
thematik an die zeit das in frage
analoge fragen auf was passiert mit
dürfte frage stelle ich hatte gleich
warum die art so diskriminierend ist ein
forum der gegensätze seriöser und
claudio zanetti schwestergesellschaft
for muslim grau ließ irgendwie stetig an
die gesellschaft wie sag mal
evangelische und katholische christen
jüdischer zu wichtig sie hängt zu fast
40 morgen korrigieren
aber ich finde es natürlich respektlos
aber natürlich das hört sie machen es
ist einfach respektlos und ein mensch wo
gewisses niveau hätte
die anklagepunkte werden auf der bühne
verhandelt im publikum ist auch georg
kreis historiker und ehemaliger
präsident der eidgenössischen kommission
gegen rassismus publikum normalerweise
eröffent licher schlagabtausch oft eben
auch gewaltig und so blut und gütlich
walid abbas twitter gehört dass der
klient eine richtige prozessoren kein
antrieb ohne debatte wie sie das will
ich das chance es ist spannend packend
mich zu wahrscheinlich mehr reagiert
heute bin ich mit dem verstand bin ich
mit dem anti verstanden wichtig ist dass
er stattfindet findet auseinandersetzung
statt und four geschafft was frank hat
sich damit hat sie sich den saal bereits
erwischt im publikum das sie über ihre
eigene wie sagt schmaler und tankt man
sich in der normalen politik ganz klar
dass es anders dank ziel verfolgen zum
gewinnen
leider eine ganz repräsentative kann
also nicht über jahre hin zu der
verschiedene aspekte meine bilder aber
man hätte eigentlich viel licht fast wie
immer eine griechische drama mit glitter
mich selber drin index sie hätte peter
seiffert noch völlig unbeteiligt
verfolgt hätte mir sie ständig nein nein
sagen im verfolger von
auseinandersetzung
die
sind theaterkritiker und srf
kulturredaktor sie hatten das publikum
gemischt strecke war sehr stark
die vita klemm die schnittstellen
zwischen inszenierung und realität
aktuell inhalt ihrer rolle da andere
hansestraße seinen eigenen aber unser
argumentiert werden sie sich aus mit
viel auf und ab erlebt als ich mir
eigentlich immer an deiner stelle wo sie
jetzt ist es mir recht gut ginge also
wenn es wirklich ins spiel gekommen
sagen plötzlich weniger interessant ist
ein kunde wenn sie so ein kleid eilig
axis an irgendwelche details
es ist natürlich nur schon insofern
theater im theater stattfindet auf die
bühne und es ist so wie sie vor seiten
die lied spielen bis ich stelle sich da
es ist auch ganz klar
es folgte der regel von einer normalen
gerichtsprozess um seine eigene regler
wo sie sich stellt und es ist natürlich
auch insofern kunst also sinnlos
probiere mich war dieses spiel hat ja
nicht rechtsverbindlichkeit
qualität ist eigentlich dass es
situation herstellt womöglich neue
diskussion um mögliche es möglich wieder
zum zum diskutieren wo ich der welt
meiner recht relevante rahmen nicht
möglich war im wald verbindet unter das
feld und wo
wo debatte ermöglichen das heute noch
mit ab jetzt zum teil statt 100 zum teil
nicht und immer einen moment wo sie aber
den bitteren ausgang ist sehr
interessant
die zweite sitzung ist zu ende sind wir
also gespannt auf den dritten tag
publikum und akteure wieder im theater
heute ist der tag der entscheidung die
geschworenen werden ihr urteil fällen
zuerst habe in die dritte
verhandlungsrunde artikel 265 des
strafgesetzbuches gefährt und der
verfassungsmäßigen ordnung
gemäß artikel 2 175 des
strafgesetzbuches macht sich schuldig
wer eine handlung vornimmt die darauf
gerichtet ist die verfassungsmäßige
ordnung der eidgenossenschaft
rechtswidrig zu stören
die anklage wirft der weltwoche vor sie
wolle das justizsystem schwächen und den
volkswillen über den rechtsstaat stellen
unter dem trommelfell und richter
unabhängig können urteile
das lenkt sie abonniert
entscheidungsfreiheit
sie werden den quasi zu instrument vor
willkürlicher volks mehrheiten und das
canada go so sieht die weltwoche die
gefahr die bundesrichter könnten sich
als eier tollers des politisch gerechten
sehen
an anderer stelle heißt es man hätte
sich an das ärgernis gewöhnt dass das
bundesgericht sich über den volkswillen
hinwegsetzt häufig urteil kritisiert
auch höchstrichterlich mehr könnte statt
nur weiterentwickeln wenn man dir kritik
breit zurück es dürfte umsturz vor dem
fundamentalwert gerichtet sie da sich im
gesetz ausgeschlossen
aber kritik buch der demokratie
artikel 275 das vielleicht schwierigste
thema juristische fragen um das
bundesgericht und volkssouveränität um
nationales und internationales recht
sollen erörtert werden
die zürcher prozesse anklagepunkt drei
gefährdung der verfassungsmäßigen
ordnung action die weltwoche zieht in
lausanne lausanne ayatollahs am werken
bundes gerichtliche entscheide geißelt
die angeklagte als sündenfälle und
politiker und rechtsprofessoren werden
wegen ihrer kritik am jahr zur
minarett-initiative als totengräber der
demokratie bezeichnet die den
volksentscheid hintertreiben wollen
ziel der weltwoche ist nicht die
beseitigung der verfassungsmäßigen
ordnung sondern die stärkung durch
kritik die medien sind in unserer
demokratie eine vierte gewalt
und das soll auch so bleiben neben
anderen zeugen wird die völkerrechts
expertin eva maria belka befragt wie
sehen sie solche kritik die fakten video
ist und wie sollen sich bundesrichter
hiergegen wären also selbstverständlich
ist kritik zu lässig es ist sogar die
wichtige funktion der medien dass sie
hier die rolle des mandat public
watchdog war nimmt und da ist der preis
den man dafür gerne pizza ist das auch
übertrieben er das nur vermeintliche
missstände angeprangert
das ist zweifellos so es gibt aber
schranken für die medienfreiheit die
sind gesetzlich festgelegt insbesondere
im strafgesetzbuch
es gibt öffentliche interessen die diese
schranken rechtfertigen etwa eben die
verfassungsmäßige ordnung nicht als ganz
selbstverständlich kann man sie enden
aber es gibt wohl fundamente an denen
wir nicht leichtfertig wechseln möchten
ulrich schlüer vater der
minarett-initiative über volksentscheide
und internationales
recht in der schweiz wird recht
überdurchschnittlich befolgt mehr als in
anderen ländern und das hängt damit
zusammen dass bei uns recht demokratisch
legitimiert ist also derjenige für den
das recht angewendet wird ist eigentlich
der überzeugen dass er selbst dabei war
als dieses recht geschaffen wurde
deshalb haben wir eine hohe rechts
disziplin in unserem land die gefährden
wir natürlich wenn ihr mit vagen begriff
von übergeordnetem recht volksentscheide
außer kraft setzen wollen
doch dann nimmt die sitzung einen
anderen verlauf plötzlich geht es um
macht um einfluss kommerzielle und
politische interessen der journalist
oder fuji im zeugenstand
können sie uns etwas berichten über die
eigentumsverhältnisse dieses land die
weltwoche gehört zu einem konzern und
wurde aus diesem konzern ausgegliedert
der eigentümer von beide vom konzern um
von dieser ausgegliedert ausgegliederter
der zeitung ist der finanzjongleur tito
tettamanti von seiner lieblingssätze war
dank dem volk kann man demokratie
demokratisch abschaffen
herr köppel sagt öffentlich hat das
mehrfach gesagt dass er selber
eigentümer und verleger der weltwoche
ist das widerspricht klar ihre aussage
dass herr tettamanti eigentümer sei wie
sollen wir das neben dem urteil
sie sollten einfach ihre eigene meinung
haben sie können sich fragen ob roger
köppel in der lage war 2 millionen cash
auf einem tischchen zu stellen muss die
gesamtkosten des verlages
wenn sie glauben dass herr köppel über
20 millionen oder auch nur zwei
millionen verfügt hat dann muss man sich
die frage stellen wie hat er sie
verdient der medien soziologe kurt imhof
beschreibt die veränderungen der
schweizer medienlandschaft in den
jahre man kann klar sagen dass die
weltwoche diskriminiert ich glaube das
hat diese verfahren auch gezeigt dass
erfolgt eben zur maximierung der
resonanz es ist ein ziel die resonanz zu
maximieren und diesem ziel gebracht eben
auch die diffamierung von bürgerinnen
und bürger mein vorredner hat darauf
hingewiesen die weltwoche wurde dann
übernommen ein doch mehrheitlich
republikanisches liberales blatt wurde
ein anti liberales blatt verwandelt
politische akteure nutzen die krise der
presse um sich eigene organe zu kaufen
und damit auf die öffentlichkeit der
republik einfluss zu nehmen
alle drei anklagepunkte sind jetzt also
verhandelt bald nach den
schlussplädoyers kommt es zum urteil der
geschworenen
nikolaus ist interesse vor dem stück
sehen die vorfall zeigt das urteil an
sich interessiert sie weniger sondern
der diskurs wozu dem urteil führt wie
hans idec diskurses erlebt als ich als
extrem spannend erlebt das war eine
große vielzahl von perspektive zweier
chor showroom quasi noch einmal
gerichtsverhandlung wird die sache auf
den grund und zum hintergrund kommen hat
eine perspektive haben mal einige von
euch also mich für etwa durch oder für
oder gegen aussage nochmals dementiert
was mehr heimisch sind streitereien der
pause also reale schritt 3 und zwar
überall lag vor der angelegenheit also
wird jetzt das moralisch verhandelt oder
eben quasi theatral juristisch tag x
offenbar sind sich der verteidiger und
der gerichts experten nicht einig und
zwar laut und deutlich mit einigen
spieler ja ich will sagen mir ist es
zeigt sich die energie für spieler lage
ist zu ernst nehmen dass sie auf den
buchstaben kinderbuch stufe der prozess
soll im stricken der anfang es gibt
vielmehr stritten im übrigen und sicher
normal in einen kosmos das spiel macht
und stichwaffen kann grüne oder
verlieren am schluss aber wenn es nicht
durch verachtung
das zeigt der ernsthaftigkeit der
diskussion und es mir als sehr wichtig
dass es die intensität
man könnte sagen die musik quasi
elitären nische was blieb der netz im
realen leben übrig vor dem theater da
ich glaube es probleme der schweizer
indes wurde training für das feuer aus
gibt einzelne sogenannte linke ihren
diskurs für die ezb so genannten rechte
ihre zitieren diskurs führt und dem
wurde das tribunal macht für symbolische
art für beispielhafte einzige
möglichkeit happy dass gemeinsam
diskutieren natürlich die handlung
wieder machen das stück russischer
symbolische handlung muss wiederholt
werden wofür den anstoß ist
das ist natürlich mit entweder die
partie mit 2 5 den frank ca
also vorhang runter und alle fragen
offen sind wir also gespannt auf die
schlussplädoyers und das urteil der
geschworenen die letzte sitzung noch
einmal treten die anklage und die
verteidigung vor die geschworenen
die zürcher prozesse
schlusssitzung
eingeschrieben
ein letztes mal face to face
wir haben in den letzten drei tagen
vorgeführt bekommen dass die weltwoche
mit dem dreischritt die familien
diskreditieren und diskriminieren einen
bestimmten stil etabliert hat und das
ist das treten nach unten aus minaretten
und kopftuch werden einzig symbole eines
aggressiven ihre glaubens aus
sozialhilfe betrügern muslimischen
glaubens werden pauschal arbeitsscheue
und betrügerische muslime wobei dann
noch so gerät wird in diskriminierende
haltung das sei könnte sogar genetisch
bedingt sein
das ist rassistisch daher bitte ich sie
sehr geehrte damen und herren geschworen
haben sie den mut die angeklagte auf
ihre gesellschaftliche verantwortung zu
verpflichten und deshalb schuldig zu
sprechen
ich danke für die aufmerksamkeit
es ist eine kampagne der anklage die
immer wieder mit wiederholungen arbeitet
die uns ein hämmert hier wo der
diffamiert hier wurde das volk verheizt
hier wurde stigmatisiert aber konkret
wirklich etwas bewiesen ist nicht
ich behaupte nun dass die anklage
letztlich genau das macht was sie der
weltwoche vorwirft dass sie nämlich mit
diffamierungen stigmatisierungen und
tatsachen widrigen behauptungen arbeitet
wenn wir meinen wir können freiheiten in
den kasten hängen und sie nicht groß
gebrauchen
wir können sie nach jahren wieder
hervorholen
dann werden wir uns wundern wie viel
motten löcher
diese freiheiten inzwischen bekommen
können
wir sollten froh sein um diejenigen die
die meinungsäusserungsfreiheit wirklich
benutzen
als vertreter der weltwoche trägt alex
baur vor das gericht
viel war in diesen tagen von geistiger
brandstiftung die rede
die spinde demnach hier als einer der
die saat rausbringt
die niere ultimative konsequenz zum
genozid führen könnte für adolf eichmann
dem organisator der show endete die
geschichte vor einem gericht in
jerusalem
seine letzte station war dann begründen
nun ich selber sehe mich und die
weltwoche
ihren geistigen erbe von hannah arendt
arndt berichtete
vor 52 jahren über den eichmann-prozess
sie brachte dabei ganz unangenehme dinge
zur sprache
die andere nicht zur sprache brachten
die welt doch als korrektiv anzuklagen
ist schlechterdings unsinn
es gibt keine von oben von einem treffen
ein führer gesteuerte gruppe und ich
kann ihnen garantieren wenn eine
minderheit in diesem land tatsächlich
unter die räder kommt wenn sie
drangsaliert und unterdrückt würde dann
bin ich sicher dass roger köppel der
erste wäre der sich dagegen stemmen
würde so gut kenne ich ihn und ich hoffe
dass auch ich den mund hätte dies zu tun
wir kommen zur urteilsverkündung die
sitzung ist eröffnet ich stehe hier vor
ihnen als sprecherin der geschworenen
und verkünde ihnen hiermit das urteil zu
der uns gestellten frage hat die
weltwoche mit den artikeln gegenstand
der anklage bildeten die grenzen der
medienfreiheit zum schaden dritter und
der zivilgesellschaft überschritten und
sich so eine verletzung ihrer
gesellschaftlich gesellschaftlichen
verantwortung schuldig gemacht ja oder
nein
das urteil lautet im stimmenverhältnis 6
zu 1 nein nicht schuldig
begründung der geschworenen die
meinungsfreiheit und meinungsvielfalt
erachten wir als ein sehr wertvolles gut
dafür stehen wir ein und darum sind wir
ab hier im fußballjargon passt für uns
das bild der ball hat die linie berührt
diese aber nicht übertreten
die anklage war das zu wenig glaubwürdig
es geschaffen zu viele angriffe
gegenüber an abwesenden die anklage hat
sich teils im selben beklagenden muster
wie die weltwoche verhalten
wir appellieren auch an den gesunden
menschenverstand der weltwoche leser
muss sich der position der weltwoche
bewusstsein bitte geschworenen sie haben
das wort ich bin auch eine derjenigen
gewesen die für den freispruch plädiert
haben
es geht darum dass wir uns in einem
graubereich bewegen was jetzt
diskriminierung ist und was nicht das
ist offensichtlich für jeden anders
dieser graubereich ist aber vermeidbar
und wenn ich auf das beispiel mit dem
fußball zurück komme wenn der fußball
dann aber die linie überschritten hat
dann ist es zu spät der schaden ist
angerichtet
und dieser schaden ist nicht so einfach
wieder gut machbar und rückgängig
machbar
deswegen denke ich dieser prozess ist
eine chance für die autoren der
weltwoche ihren kurs zu überdenken
vielen dank
das urteil ist gefällt die sieben
geschworenen haben die weltwoche
freigesprochen ist damit jetzt der
wirklich ein theater vorhang gefallen
oder bleibt real etwas von diesem spiel
zurück diskutieren sie weiter auf
unserer internetseite
sf punkt sehr schrägstrich kultur dort
können sie auch alle verhandlungen
nochmals nachsehen
rund 14 stunden prozess 45 minuten
sendung
ich erlaube mir an dieser stelle einen
persönlichen gedanken in einer der
sitzungen wurde gesagt wir lebten in
einer 20 minuten gesellschaft in der
mediale zuspitzung nahezu notwendig
seien
ich frage mich wie es denn zu dieser
gesellschaft gekommen ist inwiefern die
medien dazu beigetragen haben und welche
graustufen wir in diesem land zwischen
schwarz und weiß zu lassen wollen
kulturplatz extra auch wir schließen die
akten für heute und wünsche gute nacht